situation toujours extrêmement tendue en
côte d'ivoire où les mutins semble
s'organiser ils ont constitué ce matin
un comité de salut public
le président déchu henri konan-bédié
serait réfugiée dans un camp militaire
français paris s'apprête à renforcer son
dispositif militaire en côte d'ivoire où
les troupes françaises ont été mises ce
soir en état d' alerte maximale afin
d'être prêtes à protéger les vingt mille
ressortissants français qui y vivent
reportage de nos correspondants
permanents en afrique eric monier et
roger motte
les patrouilles se multiplient à abidjan
les suspects sont interpellés
fouillez pouvoir arrêter
le nouveau pouvoir des militaires tient
absolument à montrer qu'il a la
situation en main
il faut dire que la nuit dernière la
première sous couvre feu les pillards
civils ou soldats incontrôlés s'en sont
donné à coeur joie
désormais la consigne est claire
la fermeté est ce soir après 18 heures
le tir sans sommation le nouvel homme
fort du pays le général robert guéi a
présenté en fin de matinée un comité de
salut national de dix militaires tout en
continuant à négocier au téléphone avec
les autorités françaises un départ
rapide du président déchu
à développer leur jeu
attention lui bédié
n'est pas
le général gueï a promis la formation
prochaine d'un gouvernement de large
consensus les leaders de l'opposition
alassane ouattara et laurent gbagbo
toujours absent du pays sont invités à y
participer nous allons aller
et qui vont s'installer donc il faut le
dire qu'ils sont associés il serait
largement cerisier les militaires
ivoiriens ne semble avoir qu'une hâte
entre est d'ores et déjà dans l'après
bédié c'est le message délivré par le
général guéi aux autorités françaises et
aux diplomates américains qui l'ont
rencontré dès cet après midi